[Musique]
après avoir exhibé son torse et ses
muscles et hier le ministre de la santé
était ce matin sur france info
bonjour olivier ferrand bonjour
aujourd'hui nous traquons de larian nous
traquons dernière très active nous avons
renforcé considérablement à la tester à
l'air peut partager un torse et des
biceps beaucoup beaucoup plus musclée
que ce à quoi les internautes
s'attendait au point de troubler hommes
et femmes sur les réseaux pourquoi j'ai
envie de croire au gouvernement soudain
de voter en marche et même d'être une
aiguille demande constance julia
soulignant plus cette manière de cacher
son téton un peu plus dit kaki qui
bouleverse je te comprends mais reprend
quoique aguiar par un toit il est
caliente ce ministre écrit une jeune
fille de ministre à sex symbol il n'ya
qu'un pas un internaute aussi est un peu
jaloux à mon avis ça fait trois semaines
qu'il fait de la muscu pour paraître
costaud devant les caméras beaucoup ont
noté qu'il avait pris soin aussi de
cacher son téton certains ont carrément
lancé une pétition pour que les
révérends montre son téton lors de la
deuxième injection
sachez que les vrais fans comme ni qui n
ont pas été surprise elles savent depuis
cette photo du 28 juillet 2019 sur
instagram que oui olivier ferrand pouce
de la fonte il va à la salle on
n'attrape pas un torse par et emportant
les dossiers du ministère ont sans doute
comme quoi deux ministres à sexy ya pas
que le miracle est aussi du travail en
conclusion d'un internaute il faut
vraiment que la frustration sexuelle
soit son comble en france pour qu
l'épaule dénudée d'olivier ferrand nous
excite à ce quiz c'est un ministre de la
santé fraîchement vaccinés qui est avec
nous et ce matin puisque vous avez
receuillir la première dose du vaccin
astrazeneca car vous êtes également
médecin et donc parmi les publics
prioritaires pourquoi l'avoir fait
devant les caméras mais je me suis rendu
à l'hôpital de melun pour regarder
comment s'organiser la vaccination des
soignants de moins de 65 ans avec le
vaccin astrazeneca un vaccin qui est
arrivé samedi une des vaccinations ont
commencé dès dimanche pardon dont il
vise à relier les premiers simples
on a ça dans la gorge matinale
rassure-t-on phong pour l'heure il a
surtout très envie de se faire remarquer
car ils cherchent l'amour
seulement il a la folie des grandeurs
l'objet de ses désirs mesure 4 fois sa
taille
[Musique]
pour arriver à ses fins être flamboyant
ne suffit pas d'autres trouvent ce petit
draper très classique en effet genre
tableaux de la renaissance un cachez ce
sein que je ne saurais voir la pause
était décidément parfaite arrêter les
fantasmes pour pascal le message
subliminal est 100% républicain c'est la
liberté guidant le peuple de delacroix
bientôt l'immunité guidant le peuple on
l'espère son objectif est de déposer une
poche de sperme dans sa bouche
plus facile à dire qu'à faire il y était
presque
le roman tambour 1 200 m
nouvel essai
[Musique]
en plein dans le mille je t'aime toi le
message est clair
j'aimerais que cet amour tu le prennes
omar sy veut lancer une chaîne de
l'amour sur les réseaux sociaux donnent
le et demande à cette personne de le
donner ensuite ainsi de suite pour que
ça me reviennent oublier l'espace d'un
moment les querelles en tout genre
commençons la chaîne du love des
milliers d'internautes ont été touchés
par cette initiative et y participe avec
un gif un dessin ou une vidéo
je vous aime
[Musique]
tu dis un moment que tu prenais de la
drogue au petit déjeuner oui c'est comme
quelqu'un qui est alcoolique et qui boit
son verre d'alcool matin au réveil
moi je connais la drogue au matin au
réveil tu prenais quoi la cocaïne
c'est à dire donc le matin au réveil tu
te réveiller il faut que je me prenais
jardin prenait je prenais un trait way
jusqu'au soir et est-ce que vous est-ce
que vous avez une idée de l'âge auquel
vous souhaiteriez mourir
ivan rioufol pas si vieux c'est vrai ben
il va être temps de dépenser alors non
mais si vous dites pas ses vieux
souvenirs et en 2007 qui tente de mettre
fin à ses jours en prenant trop de
médicaments tels qu est ce que tu t'es
dit ce jour là tu t'es dit je m'en
sortirais jamais je veux arrêter je veux
pas m'en sortirais jamais j'ai voulu
mourir mon coeur on regarde le soleil
pour la dernière fois on fait un câlin à
son chien pour la dernière fois et on
prend des médicaments pour finir j'ai
essayé pas qu'une fois et c'est cette
fois est ce que vous vous dites masseur
excusez moi la question que le seigneur
vous a oublié sur terre je crois qu'il
me dis pas ce que je lui rappelle tous
les jours mais il n'est pas pressé de
vous faire monter quoi elle pourra donc
fêté son anniversaire jeudi 117 ans elle
rattrape peu à peu la doyenne de
l'humanité la japonaise akane tanaka qui
elle a donc ses 18 ans
peut-être qu'il veut que vous battiez
leur corps de jeanne calment masseur 122
euros c ou c 'est tout c'était de les
tromperies
ah oui oui oui c'était bidon ce record
là oui mais oui c'est évident au vu donc
en plus à l'état que jamais
une autre question très rapidement s'il
vous plaît elle est posée par anita elle
est conseillère funéraire son patron
l'obligent à donner des dates de ces
vacances j'ai failli m'étouffer relisant
le droit alors pas du tout venant anita
votre employeur n'a absolument pas le
droit qui était craint par les gels
tanner non là je suis pas parlé à aucune
chaîne au monde fin d'année c'est payant
ce que vous dites je pas encore par
l'ajustement de ses prochains outils
dont karim vous nous avez apporté ce qui
semble être les reliquats d'un panneau
de signalisation d'arrêt de stop pour un
bus anglais exactement une avec un avec
un trou de balle de 45 écoute les trous
de balles je ne sais ça n'avançait pas
un combat à venir qu'il n'ya pas le trou
et là on a une petite surprise dans le
coin j'ai pas pu m'empêcher royal garde
on a le trou de la petite souris
j'adore ces personnes qui sont capables
de se mouvoir sur m ou chewy génie et de
dix enfants quand ils viennent la
première chose ils vont voir la petite
trappe c'est génial et enfin pour
conclure je dirais que marques de luxe
ont dû conclure bon
[Rires]